a very warm welcome to this video on how
to get a job as a Python developer the
job of Python developer is one of the
most sought after in the market right
now and for that very reason it might
not be that simple to land this show so
in today's video I'll give you 12 tips
on how you can land this job so let's
begin tip number one build your own
github repository so go and github
create a repository and add all your
files all your Python codes on there so
doesn't matter if it's a big project or
some small piece of code where you just
took some input and made some
manipulations displayed it every work
counts learn a bit of github version
control so not only do you upload your
file once but you can make modifications
to them rework on them make it better
upload it again showing your progress
now this github repository basically
becomes your resume as a Python
developer the recruiters can look
directly on here instead of you sending
them zip files or even Jupiter notebooks
everything is now available online and
they can access it from anywhere through
any machine so this really shows that
you're not just writing code for
yourself but you want to share this with
other people and that's very important
tip number two make sure that your code
is readable so when you're putting your
code out in github as I mentioned
previously you're writing this code not
just for yourself so if people want to
learn from your code they want to view
your code it's necessary that they
understand this code and of course there
are few guidelines to follow which makes
your code more readable the most
important one being you follow the pep 8
style guideline in case of Python so the
pep Excel guidelines basically some
conventions that you use and that mainly
talks about indentation so in case of
pep 8 you have a four space indentation
tabs and spaces there's maximum line
length which in case of pepid is 79
characters per line the line breaks that
you need to put blank lines for example
every major class or every major
function needs to be separated by two
lines two blank lines the source file
encoding string codes white spaces in
expression trailing commas naming
conventions and so on so again very
basic thing if you're having a variable
make sure the variable name shows what
the variable stores what it is used
and it's not just some big names such as
bad wine bath two and so on
tip number three create a good
documentation again this helps with the
readability and the understandability of
the code so one of the main things with
creating a good documentation is having
a receive me file in your github
repository the readme file should
contain details regarding your project
what your project does the various
libraries used in your project and so on
so this is a great help to anyone who is
trying to learn from your code or
implement them in a different way now
here we have a screenshot of the readme
file created by Raymond Hettinger it's
present in his github repository now who
is a dream and heading up well that
brings us to a fourth point
Raymond Hettinger like another guy
Kenneth reads these are some of the very
popular personalities on github they
have a very unique style and a very neat
and organized style of coding and one of
the great ways to develop your own
coding skill is to look at other
people's code now when you're looking at
other people's code it's important to
remember that you look at code which is
of your own skill level so if you're an
intermediate coder make sure you look at
someone's github repository who again
codes on the intermediate level so that
you're able to connect with that code
you could probably write the same code
but he or she writes it in a better
manner now these are some of the people
who have great github repositories you
can definitely learn a lot from them tip
number five read books on Python coding
so you might know already quite a bit of
Python in fact if you are looking for a
Python developer job there's a good
chance that you are an advanced coder
but nothing beats books here are some of
the very popular and well-known books
for Python fluent Python automate the
boring stuffs with Python and so on now
fluent Python is a great book to start
with what it does it just not what it
does is it gets your Python concepts
really strong so now you'll have not
only great skills but also the perfect
way to portray these skills tip number
six draw your Python skill set of course
you can never stop learning keep
learning and some of the very important
things when you go for a Python
developer job is to make sure that you
know how to work with some of these
Python libraries in fact make sure that
while you can cover most of these
libraries there are certain ones that
you have completely mastered some of the
very popular libraries with Python numpy
scipy matplotlib tensorflow and so on
so learn these master them create
projects around them and finally put
these all up on github for everyone to
view tip number seven it's never enough
to just know a language you must know
how to apply it and with Python some of
its most important and popular
applications are in the field of AI
machine learning and data science so
master AI and machine learning with
Python learn the various algorithms that
these fields use and implement projects
on them as you can see here we have two
of the algorithms with machine learning
that's linear regression k-means
clustering neural networks is an
algorithm used with deep learning so
make sure you have some of these
applications are there in your
repository this displays your skill not
only in Python but also in other fields
and both of these going hand-in-hand
just increases your value tip number
eight take freelancing projects to start
off with so so far I mentioned how you
write your own code you create your own
projects now that's not enough take up
projects by companies now these may be
non paid they may be really loop it does
not matter as long as you have something
to show off so you have a project under
your belt that really pays off now some
of the websites you can go to for
freelancing works are freelancer up work
drog or true Lancer comm and so on so
this really shows to the recruiter that
this person did not just live on Python
but he or she is always looking at how
to implement them how to use them
tip number nine make open source
contributions so you have your own
github repository that's great but now
look into others repositories see if
there's some value that you can add and
if you can definitely go for it this
shows not only your skill but also that
you're a team player you want to add
value to work that is already existing
and that is a skill that again really
valued in organizations so some of the
popular ones include pip IND which is
the Python development workflow for
humans
there's also chata Stix where you can
convert your messenger and hang out chat
logs into data frames then you can solve
your travelling
salesman problems using self-organizing
maps and there's also a peyten
to BPF converter so these are great
places to make your contributions in
fact we have the links for some of these
in the description below so please check
them out
tip number 10 start a blog and talk
about what you have learned so having
your own person blog will add a lot of
credibility to your profile in your blog
you can definitely mention where you
started off from that is at a beginner
level what all did you know how you took
on your journey to where you are now
what materials you used to collect
information and what projects you took
on how you went about this mention any
papers you wrote and so on all this
again becomes another profile for you
the recruiters can have a quick look at
your personal blog and have a good idea
of what kind of a learner you are what
kind of a coder you are and if you have
done everything right this could create
a great impression on the recruiters and
if you have done everything right this
will create a great mark on the
recruiters so here's a screen shot on
net bachelor's blog on peyten
it will give you a good idea as to how
to create a blog and how to go about it
so please check that out
so here's a list of all his blog posts
he has 227 blocks just for Pythian and
he writes on various topics for example
here we have a screen shot of a spy teen
interpreted or compiled in fact you can
even include some of your personal views
on Pythian on the learning process or
the learning curve of Python and so on
tip number 11 follow a daily schedule
for practice so just because you think
you have mastered the language do not
put it aside and let it collect dust
take out some time every day write code
whether small or big make sure that
every aspect of Python is at your
fingertips and finally tip number 12
keep your resume and profile updated on
job portals such as LinkedIn indeed last
oh and Careerbuilder look out for Python
developer job roles on these site and
Google jobs simply hired eyes and more a
recently updated resume always captures
the eye of the recruiter so these are
some of the tips you can follow to bag
the Python developers job if you're new
to Python and require
some help in gaining the skills to
attain that job of a Python developer
you have come to the right place just go
to our website simply learn comm and in
here we have just the course for you in
fact we have a number of courses for
Python but you can start off here with
Python training course this course
covers everything a to z for python and
it's pretty much all you require to get
that job so before you take up the
course you can definitely go through
everything that it covers the objectives
who should take up this course the
prerequisites what projects are covered
under the course and also the
subheadings of the various topics
covered so I hope this video was helpful
if yes please hit the like button also
subscribe to our channel if you haven't
already all the best and see y'all next
time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here